これじゃあ外れ雪道で再掲俺に足りないものは何かボレーに今足りないものは何かそれ
は長い時間 youtube を続けて版べきだと思っていた俺にまだてないものが
それ何かそう
筋肉まあそうフリスク打撃打撃を食らうことが多くなると思う今後の youtube
は物理的な打撃が多くなると思うんでちょっとフィジカルの長は期待まあこう
ゲキを受けても動じない強い防御力を手に入れるためにちょっとハリセンを準備しまし
たこちら
big ハリセンお札柄なんだね何って言うからだ
おおーーなかなかいいんじゃないすかいいでビッグはりせんだね
ああ
いい感じだ本来後野芝供養ハリセンを10個準備しました
俺も普通の敗戦で叩かれてもダメージ受けね七戸の住戸のプレゼンをくっつけて衆生西
競技力のある配線をつくってさあ日本がちょっといじり者とかね色んなものを用意して
2のうまい具合に改造して自動的にあの僕を投げてくれるハリセンマシンを作って
みようと思いますなありっ子
食べられる
まあに心配はいらないどっちっおよびでまずはこの貼り全10頭口つけて巨大な
ハリセンを作ってみようと思います
出合小望星の部分をガムテープでくっつけます
持ち手をしっかりすることでちゃんとなると思うんです
a 無理だった
そういい感じいい感じかいいねいいですよね余ってこれさえ逆じゃねえパッチば手数に
落下した完全に見せたところがあれば良いんだ
知った
ちょっとやり直しますごめんなさい
あああ
たいい感じいい感じ落ちて完成しましたでもここがまだくっついてないのでガムテープ
で貼られているところをくっつけてきます
できましたこれでも全部繋がってました
tan
はいだけでこれをですねいかにしてマシンポッケが僕にぶつける形作戦です威力を上げ
てい g 車のホイールこの足を踏むところにうまいことハリセンを続ければ半永久的
に僕を探り
半永久的に僕だけで続ければ麦やはりせマシーンが作れると思いますどうすればいい
からもうあなぶなるほど悪くはないんだと
こういう感じですバッチリ来て足してやるのでお店のこっちのハンドルを回すと
た
ネッツ待って超えちゃった売れだぽなぁ髪も伝えているとここが壊れちゃうんでパク
さんかいます毛頭なるバシッと一発でいきましょう市内を使います
剣道部の人ごめんなさいや薄いのでしかねーよしないお方いう感じで安全に括りつけ
ます
こんな感じでつけていましたしないがさんのくっついていることが確かめてみましょう
だ
閾値グっていう教えないの先にハリセンをつけて事務所の回転力の遠心力を使ったもう
最高速度のスピードで貼り全振りを通して自分の防御力は餃子を見ます
行け動かすみたいなこれで動けば成功です
もういいよこれ嘘えっ
またまたまたまたバック
えっ
あっはっは
はぁはいと言うけど無事自動配線た時ませんかんた自動ではね普通どうビッグハリセン
た時マシン完成ですこれによって僕は自らを痛めつけ新た月からを見に行って
フィジカル最強のユーチューバーとしてなんて客さんあそこら辺を全部倒しますでは
いごっそよろしくお願います
水2うわぁ
あんまり食べないと
これ普通に行ったほうが痛いバーッ
ます
ten
th
しています